[Music]
it's possible to use bigquery to analyze
data without a credit card by setting up
the bigquery sandbox environment this
video will show you how to set up your
own bigquery sandbox start by navigating
to the bigquery web UI at console cloud
google.com slash bigquery log into your
Google account or create a new account
if you do not already have one if you
are logging into Google cloud for the
first time you will need to choose your
country and accept the Terms of Service
click agree and continue in order to use
the bigquery sandbox you must create a
project enter a project name and click
create once the project is created you
will be redirected to the bigquery web
UI notice the sandbox banner indicator
in the upper left-hand corner of the
console congratulations you are now
ready to start using the bigquery
sandbox you can load our query data in
this project without an attached billing
accounts usage will be limited to the
same limits as the free tier which can
be viewed at cloud.google.com slash free
any tables views or partitions and
partition tables automatically expire
after 60 days to overcome these sandbox
limits you can choose to upgrade your
project by enabling billing and removing
or updating the expiration time for your
resources happy analyzing
you
[Music]